So in summary and revenue model for this class,
the best thing that you could do is start drawing the diagram.
So what I want you to do is draw the diagram
of both your revenue streams and your pricing,
and I want you to actually put numbers in.
So let's assume this is your company over here.
What you've discovered is that there are 3 different customer segments; look at that.
Tenants, property owners, and leasing companies.
I want to know if this is subscription, what is the revenue stream
that you have between each one of these customer segments,
and what are the pricing tactics?
And then how do you make money and what do you provide.
And out of sudden you can now see
that the revenue stream and the pricing is going back and forth.
I just really believe that if you could draw you have a handle on understanding it.
And don't worry, on day one you start drawing and then realize
I really don't understand this stuff.
That's just a signal - time to get out of building again,
talk to some more people and say:
well, how are we gonna make money here?
Cause i can't even explain it to myself.